it allows us to narrow down the
possibilities of what the zeros are of
the function whether they're positive
negative or imaginary and the way that
you do this is I'm going to show you
through an example here is you look at
how many times the sign changes so from
positive and negative or negative to
positive so in this first example what
you can see is we're going from a
positive x cubed to negative 7 x squared
so that's one sign change negative to
negative
that doesn't change signs and negative
to negative that also doesn't change
signs so what that tells us is that we
have a maximum of one positive zero okay
so that means we're going to have a
maximum of one now what we're gonna do
is were in a substitute in negative X
into our function and we're going to
analyze the sign changes after we
simplify the function with negative x
substituted in place of x so here we're
going to get negative x cubed negative
7x squared because a negative squared is
positive negative times negative gives
you positive 10x minus 8 okay so now
let's count the sign changes we have
negative 2 negative negative 2 positive
that's 1 positive and negative that's 2
so that means that we have a maximum of
2 positive I'm sorry two negative zeros
so what that means is on your graph it's
going to cross over here in the negative
ok range a maximum of twice and then the
positive range a maximum of once but
these are the maximums okay and what you
can see is this is a third degree so as
we add across this row here these add up
to 3 but when you have real coefficients
these numbers here in front of the
variables if these are all real then if
you have any complex roots complex zeros
imaginary solutions they're going to
come in what they call conjugate pairs
so for example you could have
two imaginary zero negative and one
positive so when you work with Descartes
rule of signs you take these maximum
values and you can decrease them by 2 4
6 8 by groups of to the imaginary ones
are going to increase by groups of two
so this one I wasn't able to subtract 2
from because that would put me into the
negative number of positive zeros you
can't have a negative number of positive
zeros and you can't take away an odd
number only an even amount so take 2 for
6 away and these are going to increase
by 2 for 6 so these are our only
possibilities okay for the zeros for
this function so if I was doing
synthetic division and I was looking for
a possible 0 I would start by looking
for a positive 1 first because I know
that there's at least one positive one
if it's this scenario here I might be
looking for a while for a negative 0 and
not actually be able to find one because
it there's just going to be two
imaginary and one positive so what
Descartes rule science does it helps you
narrow down your choices when you're
doing the synthetic division to find
possible rational roots ok so let's take
a look at another example this example
here let's count the number of sign
changes so we have positive 2 positive
positive and negative that's 1 negative
2 negative doesn't change negative to
positive that's another one so what we
have here is let's make another one of
our charts positive negative imaginary
we're going to have a maximum of two
positive zeros if we substitute a
negative x we're gonna get ok so F of
negative x we're gonna get three times
negative x to the fourth plus two times
negative x cubed minus five times
negative x squared minus eight times
negative x plus one okay so here if we
simplify we get positive 3x to the
fourth because a negative to demon power
is positive we're going to get minus two
x cubed
we're going to get minus 5x squared
we're going to get positive 8x and plus
one so now let's count the number of
sign changes we have positive and
negative that's one negative and
negative that doesn't change negative
positive that's two positive positive
that doesn't change so we have a maximum
of two negative zeros okay so these are
the maximums and if we add across two
plus two plus zero gives us four and the
maximum number of zeros you can have is
whatever the highest degree of the
polynomial is which in this case is four
okay so let's look at some other
possibilities we could have two positive
zero negative and two imaginary notice
how this went but down by two and this
increased by to the imaginary zeros or
we could have zero positive to negative
and two imaginary again notice these add
up to four as you add across or we can
have zero positive zero negative and for
complex or imaginary roots so these are
the possibilities for this polynomial
okay this function and this didn't
really help us a whole lot because in
this example here we knew that we're
going to have at least one positive root
so we could go and try and find that one
here though you know you'll get
sometimes like the scenario where like
say for example you'll have positive
negative imaginary you'll have zero
negative roots so you say well let me
just focus on finding the positive ones
or vice first so they might be zero
positive and some number of negative
ones and then you can just focus on
finding you know one of one or the other
depending on what the table does and
shows you so these have been some
examples here of how to use Descartes
rule of signs to to narrow down the
number of you know choices that you're
going to use when you do your synthetic
division so like just to show you just a
little bit more about this one here if I
was doing synthetic division okay I've
got one negative seven negative 10 and
negative eight and since I found out
there was at least one positive
zero let me just try for example P over
Q okay so all the factors of eight over
all the factors of one so I know that
one might be a possible route so let's
do the synthetic division multiply add
let's make sure it is right one negative
seven a of ten eighty eight so that's
going to give you a negative sixteen
that's going to give you sixteen that's
eight so that's not a zero so you would
just continue on testing the possible
rational roots to see but we know that
there's at least one positive one so
this has been how to use Descartes rule
of signs I'll see you in the next video